*Roundabout plays*
*pewds waves hand and stares into your soul....*
Hey, how's it goin' brrrroooos?
Today
is another one of those days
It's so late
Oh, my god, it's so late
It's so early. I'm such a hard worker
But I need to record a video
And I got a pretty good one.
Hey, 'member the 'to be continued' memes?
Pewdiepie, last to the meme - again.
You got me.
That's hilarious
Why did I do that?
For no reason
We're gonna watch some 'to be continued' memes
'Cause they're funny.
Let's have a look.
*Roundabout plays again*
Oh, boy!
It's a guy rock climbing
I wonder what can go wrong here?
He's getting ready to jump
OH MY GOD
What the fuck? I need to know what happened!
Now, if you guys don't know, it's
This meme ca-came from the anime, JoJo's Bizarre Adventure
It's just a cliffhanger. This is literally a cliff - cliff JUMPER. Am I right?
I need to find the original
Where do we have it?
Is this the one?
Man survives...
Dammit!
Is this the jump?
This is the jump.
This is the jump. Okay.
Does he make it?
Oh-Oh, my god, he made it
Oh, my god, he *made* it!
How?
Ooouhhh!
Oh, I /hate/ it!
I /hate/ it!
Ughhh
Fuckin' idiot
'Ouh, I love the adrenaline.' Fuckin' moron, Jesus Christ--
*Roundabout plays again*
Oh, great.
More life threatening situations.
It's just - It's just lions. They're just cute. They're just chi - Oh, geez
What's gonna happen?
That's the thing; you never know.-
OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOH
*signature pewds laugh*
Oh, I love how it ends just in that sheer panic moment.
'Cause we've all had that one moment.
Where everything is fun and games and then all of a sudden: OH MY GOD
It's kind of like - You could do one when, uh, Michael got stuck in the police car.
[Felix] See ya, Michael!
[Michael] No *gasp*
Nah, it wouldn't really work. But still.
*Roundabout plays*
Oh, wow, it's a -
[baby screams]
Hey, look, it's Michael!
What the fuck was that?
[more screaming]
*laughter*
That's the shittiest one I've ever fucking seen. What the fuck was that?
It's Pokemon
It's an evolution
It's gonna smash it
*laughter*
Oh, that poor thing.
Ooh, Dark Souls.
It's shooting arrows at him.
In a safe distance...
*laughter*
/That's/ good.
That's really good
Jesus Christ, that face is fucking terrifying.
'I'm feeling a little scared.' From what?
*man kicks woman
OOOH!
No!
*laughs*
Do-hhgfjh
*groans*
Why would you do that? Why would you do that? Why would you do -
Alright, great, now I can never trust a man to kick an apple off my - what is that called? Where does that originate from?
Oh, that's right! He had to shoot an apple off his son's head to save his life.
Look at that guy's face. That's my face. Zoom in on this guy. That's me.
Literally me. 'Fuck man'
*dancing*
Well, I, you know...
I didn't think that could get any shittier but here we have one with Jack.
[Jack] To be continued memes.
[J] They're the best.
*Roundabout again*
[F] They're the best.
[F] Except this one.
*Roundabout*
Oh, I've seen this one!
That one is /insane/!
That one is /fucking/ insane.
I gotta show you guys that one.
How do - How do these people survive, ya know? People die from so many weird, fuckin' random shit.
How do they survive this? This one is so fucking cool
'Cause - 'cause sadly everyone lives in this one
Why is he hanging on the fucking wind to begin with?
Look at him! They're going too close!
*groans*
Fuck!
Ouh, it hurts!
I - What - It hurts!
It feel - I /feel/ it!
I don't /like/ it!
*I Believe I Can Fly plays*
[Woman in video] A high five in midair should have been a tip-off, but some pet lovers were upset.
What the fuck is wrong with people? That's - Cats can't high five
This is torture!
[Woman in video] - Cats, the magic of green screen.
I wonder if they land on their feet, though.
*Roundabout*
[Woman on video] - Then he licked his chops.
Ooh, pug!
[Woman on video] - rescue dogs skydive strapped to her owner.
[Man in video] She has her own oxygen mask, her own goggles
But why?
But WHY?
I'm getting a little sidetracked, but why the /fuck/ would you do that?
I wouldn't bring Slippy up in the air.
That'd be kind of co-
*you get the drill*
*indistinct talking*
*dumb-ass falls*
Part of me just wants them to die!
I don't know. I think part of me is sad that I can't see them die.
*Roundabout*
*laughter*
See, these don't - Okay, it's funny, alright?
But it don't work. I saw what happened, alright?
The - the thing that you /don't/ know what happened. That's the joy of it.
Did he die or not?
Clearly he's just gonna get hurt. I wanna know if they died.
*Megalovania plays*
I know it's a little morbid and weird of me to say that, but it's true.
Is this gonna - it's gonna be like 'oh, is he gonna fall?' yeah.
He's gonna fuckin' fall in the water and scream like a little bitch.
There's no 'to be continued' there unless he breaks his leg or some shit, like I don't care
*Roundabout*
Okay, that one's funny
Okay, that one's funny.
*man shouting*
*man shouts then cut off*
[F] *laughing*
*man jumps off cliff brings dumb-ass that didnt tie the rope to anything*
AAAHH!
UUUIIHHH!
What happened?!
See, that's what I'm talkin' about!
If you don't know if they -
I mean, I'm /sure/ they died
Ohuuh, let me just take this second and moment also to just say, 'What the fuck, Russians. What is wrong with you?'
'Do you have - Do you not have internet in Russia? To do other things than jumping off a fucking building?'
Why's that fucking - That is fake.
'Cause he's wearing a suit.
I - There may - Okay, I get it. It's fake
Dammit. I wanted him to die.
Why do I say that? What's wrong with me?
*Megalovania plays*
See, I know what's gonna happen! He shot the shotgun! C'mon.
Fuckin' learn how to do these memes, alright?
Or fuck off.
Not funny.
He's gonna fall.
This might be good.
No, it's not.
Unless he breaks his neck, I don't care.
Okay, I don't care.
Oh, no, he fell.
Are you fuckin' retarded, whoever makes these?
[Keemstar ranting about something and then becomes and outdated meme by saying nigge-]
*laughter*
Jesus Christ. May. I'm reacting to such fucking ol -
[Woman in video] Is the weed on the show real?
*laughter*
Good job, okay?
At least some people have a sense of fucking humor.
[Man in video] Who the hell would wanna smell like Africa?
*laughter*
Okay, fine.
Oh!
*fap* fap*fap*fap*
Yes!!
*laughing*
I mean noo! No!
No.
*laughter*
Oh, my god.*cringes*
You can hear the Playstation music, too.
How long does this go on?
He's having a wank, isn't he?
[Man in video] What is up everyone?
[M] Hello, hello and welcome.
[M] Oh! Camera's on!
*laughter*
'Oh, the camera's on!'
That face.
[Man in video] When I say jump, okay?
[M] Jump!
*thud*
*laughter*
I know it's a kid but it's still funny, okay?
I can't wait to have kids just to fuck with them.
Fu -
[Woman gasping, sniggering]
That was it?
Oh!
OOOOOOH!
The plot twist!
*laughter*
Oooh, shit.
[Man in video laughing]
*giggles*
What the fuck?
[Man in video laughing]
I'm so confused. I am so. Confused.
I - That is me right now.
Alright, guys, I hope you enjoyed this video. If you did go ahead and leave a like and check out another video.
And as always...
*i'll be the roundabout*
Stay awesome, bros